and welcome back everybody we have an
update for you right now on the murder
of four University of Idaho students a
source has provided more information
about why a roommate who allegedly saw
the murderer didn't call 9-1-1 right
away the roommate referred to as DM in
the probable cause affidavit told the
source that she thought noises she heard
were from people in the house partying
late into the night the house on King
Road was known for having lots of people
in and out at all hours four people were
stabbed to death inside of that home in
November where two roommates actually
survived now DM one of those roommates
told police that she opened her bedroom
door at one point and saw a man walking
by her wearing all black and a mask she
told the source that she thought he must
be one of a guests of one of the other
roommates he walked right past her and
she looked locked herself in a room now
no one called 9-1-1 until lunchtime the
next day police ended up arresting Brian
coburger a doctoral student in nearby
Washington State University more than a
month after the murder saying he he was
the man who committed the brutal
stabbings DM's memory now seems to be a
bit different from what she told
investigators because in her latest
recollection she wasn't frightened by
the random man in the hallway but you
know what memory can be a tricky thing
so we spoke with an expert about how
memories can change over time
well you don't need a PhD to know that
as time passes our memories begin to
fade uh they become weaker but what's
not so much a matter of Common Sense is
that that weakening memory that's fading
uh with the passage of time becomes more
and more vulnerable to potential
contamination and contamination can
happen when you get suggestive
information from other sources if you're
questioned in a biased or
leading fashion if you overhear other
people talk about what happened it can
affect you but it we also can alter our
own memories that's called Auto
suggestion we think about what might
have happened what probably happened
what could have happened and sometimes
those what could have become what did
and we've also learned that suspect
Brian coburger was experiencing some
workplace drama around the time of the
murders he was apparently fired from his
position as a teaching assistant at WSU
news Nation got a copy of the alleged
termination letter and co-burger was a
TA with the Department of Criminal
Justice and criminology criminology the
letter states that Coburg coburger had
an altercation with a professor in
September where he was put on an
improvement plan but evidently had
another altercation with the same
professor in December before coburger
went to Pennsylvania to stay with his
parents for the Christmas holiday he was
informed about his termination experts
told news nation that problems of the
job could have been triggering for him
so Brian a lot to talk about here the
roommate's explanation of seeing who she
believed to be co-burger and why she
didn't call 911 right away how does that
affect the case so two things Jesse even
from her first kind of explanation of
what happened when she said she opened
the door and saw the person pass by she
doesn't say how far she opens that door
I think and I suspect it was just her
crack I think the defense can hop on
that but the second part is this whole
memory issue if her memory seems to be
contaminated with her own thoughts or
suggests a questioning and going back
and forth like this don't forget her
memory connects us to the bushy eyebrows
connects us to where he stepped
supposedly for that footprint and also
connects to his size these are Big parts
of the affidavit that led to the arrest
and could be big parts of this case that
identifies co-burger as the suspect if
they can shake up they being the defense
her memory of the events it could be
detrimental for the prosecution's case
oh I agree with you but Terry everyone's
been looking for a motive about why he
might have done this or allegedly done
this problems at work termination could
that be a factor absolutely listen the
murders occurred November 13th and he
really had the first altercation in
September and he was supposed to be on
an improvement plan and he failed that
Improvement plan and ultimately November
2nd was when he got that plan and that
was right before the murder so I
definitely think he was wondering
whether or not he was going to be fired
and he was worried about his job he was
worried about the fact he may not
actually get his PhD and this could have
been a tributing factor to the murder
now obviously he didn't get terminated
till after the murders but all of this
must have been going through his mind
and I think it just escalated because he
continued to have other altercations
even after the murders yeah we have the
how we have the when we have the where
it is the why that is that outstanding
question